more than 90 million Americans buy
athletic shoes every year the sneaker
start-up all birds have you heard of it
is working to increase its share of the
market a lot of you have because in its
first two years the company is sole
listen to this more than a million pairs
of shoes in two years San
francisco-based all bird says it's
committed to using sustainable
environmental practices to make what it
calls the world's most comfortable shoe
it's already known for its wool sneaker
but today starting today the company is
launching tree that's a new line of
shoes with material source from
eucalyptus Tim Brown and Joey is
Willinger are the co-founders and coats
as it right you got it
I've been practicing Joey co-founders
and co-ceos of all birds we welcome you
guys to the table you know before we
went to break I said it's like walking
on marshmallows that's how comfortable I
think it is and Tony our resident cranky
Yankee said Gayle who wants to walk on
marshmallows because it gets stuck
between your toes the example I was
making is that they're so soft and cushy
that's the only point I was making about
that you would agree with me about that
so cut to the resident cranky Yankee
Tony Tony we're gonna give you a pair of
all birds but listen this idea we really
should thank your wives because your
wives were college roommates and they
introduced the two of you they said what
they said don't mess up our friendship
uh-huh yeah but you guys potentially
there's a business here you should do it
together why cuz you were a former
soccer player was your chemical engineer
yep so you said you invited him over for
a romantic dinner Joey well he was where
marshmallows involved in it yeah maybe
maybe for dessert I don't remember but
there was there was he was in London and
had been doing a fantastic job with the
early iterations of what's now all birds
and and what's been a fantastic two
years as you mentioned and and I think
we just wanted to explore together if
there's something big that we could do
and he flew out from London my family
was gone I did cook him a lamb stew we
enjoyed that we enjoyed the food and the
irony of doing lamb with wool shoes and
what's what you said we want to do what
yeah we really what we gravitate around
was this idea that the cat
we'll shoot space in particular there
there was this trend where everything
was adding more and more and more flashy
logos more seams everything that wasn't
doing something for comfort so if we
could strip everything down to its
simplest form remove everything that
wasn't functional we thought that we
could make something quite beautiful out
of that from the simplicity and we could
derive this amazing comfort from merino
wool and this particular fabric that we
were in the process of Co developing
with a mill outside of Italy and outside
of Milan and Italy mm-hmm and we thought
we could do really comfortable shoes
into a space that's enormous yeah yeah
well you've been they've been incredibly
popular so why now are you moving beyond
wool the wool is fantastic incredibly
comfortable when it gets really hot it's
not as good so we tried to find a new
material that worked when when when the
weather was warm how did you hit on that
without a car eucalyptus it's got a
cooling cooling properties so it was
perfect for the problem that we'd
identified and so we set out to try and
solve it it took two years to work it
out and we launched it today so you call
this that it's new tree material free
material it doesn't sound cuddly but
nobody like the eucalyptus tree doesn't
sound sooo cuddly but this this thing
has these amazing properties where you
touch it and all of a sudden it's got
this nice cooling sensation silky soft
hand feel and we've left a couple notes
of our of our superfine merino on the
inside on the top of the insole cover
and and in the heel cup we're comfort
really matters for inside the process
what takes two years are you trying out
other materials is it things what are
you having to tweaked along the line
yeah I mean it's hard once we found the
fiber and we knew that it had this
amazing property and it cooled and give
you a delightful experience on your feet
it still was a long road for us to get
to a yarn we took that fiber and then we
made it into a yarn that was perfect for
shoes and was tough enough for the
challenges of being on your feet all day
and then we had to figure out this new
knitting technology because we really
wanted to accentuate that breeziness
with this new knit so this knitting
process is a software enabled knitting
process and it gives you just the
perfect amount of breathability where
you need it
durability where you need the durability
on the sides I'd say this joy I started
just by the shoes and try them and see
although I love it but I think what you
guys do together I think is very cool
you're always asking is there a better
way to do things and in your office
you insist that everybody work as a
receptionist including yourselves at the
company you want everybody to try all
the different jobs why do you think that
that's important we've got a team of
nearly a hundred people that know
largely nothing about shoes we're
attacking this industry at category
that's 100 hundred years hundreds of
years old
yeah it's very old fashioned in the way
the way that it does things and we've
we've we've got this incredibly talented
group of people that are pulling
together trying to tack this tackle this
very complicated problem to bring
sustainable materials into Footwear and
it's it's it's about sharing that
challenge so we've all tried to muck and
roll our sleeves up and that's what
that's about well when I saw your names
on the grid that you were coming I was
so excited because my son gave me a pair
of these two years ago and I just gave
Oprah pair for her birthday
it's very good night thank moss-green
why and what does she think right now
the next time we'll have your
receptionist here